- Have you guys ever
had pregnancy scares
with women you were dating?
I mean I'm sure there have
- Kind of, yeah.
I mean, I've had like
condoms break or like
the condom go out, pull
like inside like that, yeah.
- Or like not
being used condoms?
- Right. Or just like an
unused condom (laughter)
but I still blame the condom,
(laughter)
- Wait, you didn't
even get in there.
- This condom didn't come
out of the wrapper on its own
and put itself on my dick.
(laughter)
I mean someone had a story
about getting pregnant
even after they took
the morning after pill.
- Yeah.
- [Nikki] So like there's no,
- Some babies just
wanna be born.
- But then you're like that's
a baby that I wanna keep
'cause you survived
the morning after pill
and he's just like retarded.
(laughter)
- Hands are misshapen
and shit, yeah.
- Mike, I love you're
still using that word just,
- Me?
- [Nikki] Yeah.
- His brother's,
- My brother is.
- [Nikki] Oh? So that
gives you a right?
Why are, so is he okay
with you saying the R word?
- Sure. But ah
(laughter).
(upbeat rock music)
- I went on vacation
with my dad this weekend
and we got back from the
airport at like maybe three
in the morning and my mom
had left us a sandwich.
But the thing my
brother is like,
if there's food in the house,
he'll eat the whole bag.
So you have to hide,
- Right
- [Mike] Your snacks,
or he'll, you know.
- What does he have actually?
- He has like severe autism,
so he's like kind of non verbal.
But me and my dad just had
this moment where we're like
we wanted chips with our
sandwich and we were just like
looking around the house at
three in the morning trying
to figure out where my
mom could have hid chips
(laughter) like there's a
fucking bear that was there.
- Chips treasure.
- [Mike] Yeah, yeah
(laughter)
- So if he gets into something,
he'll make himself sick
by eating all of it?
- Yeah, he'll eat the
whole bag and if you try
to take it away from him,
- Maybe he's just high.
- He'll get upset.
- [Mike] Good luck.
- Yeah, yeah. How old is he?
- He's 20? He just turned 28?
- Okay, so he's
younger than you?
- [Mike] Yeah.
- What was that like
growing up with?
- [Mike] It was fine.
- When did he start
showing signs of it?
- Like, when he was two.
- [Nikki] Okay.
- He was like a
normal baby, too.
- [Nikki] Right.
- You know, talk and stuff.
- He was killing it.
(laughter)
- And what were the first
signs? Do you remember?
- He would like talk as a baby,
he would say like mom and dad
and then he would just
kinda like shut off.
And I remember like,
when my mom was
like your brother is autistic.
I thought it was weird
because he was like normal.
So I didn't think it
was going to be that.
- Right. And then what's
been the worst of it?
- Just like, you know,
tantrums and stuff like that.
- Is he ever gonna be
able to live on his own?
- I don't think so.
- Oh, that sucks.
- [Mike] Yeah, at 36 he'll
like get his first job
(laughter) and an apartment.
- He's just gonna snap into it.
- What does he do he do at 28,
what's he doing
now with his life?
- He just kinda
hangs out at home.
- Does he have a job
or is he able to not,
- He had one, but
then I think like,
grabbed a lady or something.
- [Nikki] Yeah,
- And they had to fire him.
- He squeezed a rabbit.
- He was working at the Wawa.
That was a good one, Tom.
(laughter) I never heard that.
- I mean you said he grabbed
a woman, it wasn't that
- That's the hackiest way to
make fun of retarded person.
- Oh, come on.
- I hope you feel
good about yourself.
That's a human
being with feelings.
- [Nikki] I think
using that word,
- Fucking piece of shit,
- You keep saying
retarded, you asshole.
- [Nikki] I know, you're the,
- C'mon, squeeze a rabbit?
- Well, come on.
- I liked it. I didn't hate it.
- You said he grabbed a woman!
- Everybody goes right
to squeeze a rabbit.
My brother gets
me, too. (laughs)
- Buy a rabbit?
- Does he know who you, I
mean, obviously he knows,
can he talk at all?
- [Mike] Yeah, a little bit.
- [Nikki] A little bit?
- Answer questions and stuff.
- [Nikki] Yeah, yeah.
Do you see him often?
- Yeah, when I go home.
- [Nikki] Right.
- I'm sorry I'm having so
many questions about this,
but it is kinda fascinating.
Do you have other siblings?
- Yeah, two other siblings.
- And do they know,
- Do they have,
- like what causes it?
- Probably. I probably
have some, a little bit,
- Probably?
(laughter)
- But I was never like,
just totally ignored.
- That's what I'm getting at.
No, it's not where
I'm getting at.
But I definitely,
(laughs)
Mike, you have
something going on.
- I, yeah, what do you
mean? I don't know.
- I mean you're
hyper intelligent,
you write really crazy,
like I feel there's
some form of,
- No one's ever called
my hyper intelligent.
- I think you are.
- [Mike] Thanks.
- In terms of joke writing,
like, you can't write jokes
like you write without being
smart and some weird way.
- Yeah.
- Thanks, guys.
- You have a specific
smart about you,
- [Tom] I think it's
fine. I stand corrected.
(laughs)
- Tom smashes the
bottle over your head.
- No, you have some
great jokes, but yeah,
I feel like there's
something spectrumy
about your intelligence.
- I will, like, like,
- And the way the way you behave
- Interact with people
- Yeah, interact with people.
Can't make I contact.
- [Tom] Right.
- I'm making eye contact
with you right now.
- No, there was an entire
episode where Mike,
- [Ian] Yeah, but your kinda
like looking through her.
- Where Mike wouldn't look
at my cohost in the eyes
for an entire hour.
- Because we did a
show about Limp Bizkit,
and I came on to talk
about Limp Bizkit,
'cause I'm a fan, and
then the whole time
Tommy was like this
music sucks, I hate it.
But the whole podcast he was
pretending to like Limp Bizkit.
- Okay.
- [Mike] So I felt
a little betrayed.
- [Nikki] And so you,
- I felt a little,
- Man, if someone
betrays you, you get so,
(laughter) we're very
similar in that way.
Like, if you get
hurt do you go after,
like do you, how do you
handle if someone betrays you?
- I don't have a lot of enemies.
But I feel if I did,
I would destroy them.
- Do what?
(laughs)
If you had to have a,
if someone hurt you,
you would come after
them, in like weird ways.
Which we'll get to
later on in the show.
Because, I hurt you
and you came after me
in the weirdest, weirdest way.
- No, it's not true.
- Some would say it
was an autistic way.
- How do you say
that is not true?
- I don't think
I came after you.
I think I wanted to,
- You wanted to hurt me.
- I wanted. No.
- Really? Okay, well
we'll talk about it.
Mike and I have some
history and he definitely
did something which I
do not begrudge you,
because I have done dirty,
dirty things to men who have
hurt me and men who
have rejected me.
I've done some mean
things I'm not proud of.
- The only thing I
did was I went through
your garbage that one time.
(laughs)
- So, Mike and I make
out in Atlantic City.
It's just a casual, fun thing.
I was just like, oh I can
just like make out with a boy.
- Not for me.
(nervous laugh)
- It wasn't casual
and fun for me.
- I did not know that it
wasn't casual and fun for Mike.
I didn't, of course I, I had
a feeling Mike had crush on me
because he can't
really hide how he is.
He just like, is, you know,
you're not really good
at masking your emotions.
Like, right now (laughter)
Right now you want to
punch me in the arm.
- No, I don't want to punch you.
And I wasn't even,
- You wanna change seats?
- I'm telling you,
like I was mad when
I texted you that night when
you were doing that taping
with Schumer and
Feinstein, you like
- Oh, I don't remember that.
- [Mike] You kinda
- I blew you off?
- Yeah, but you were
taping a TV thing,
- [Nikki] Yeah.
- And you text me back.
And there was no
service in the thing
and I was like stay the
fuck away from me forever.
- You said that to me?
- I think so, yeah.
- [Nikki] Yeah,
that seems right.
- [Mike] Yeah, but I wasn't,
- I remember there
were a couple moments
- [Mike] I was mad
when I wrote sketch,
- with you where I was
like, you need to my number.
You're crazy. And I
don't like you. (laughs)
I do remember there were
a couple of times where
I was a little bit
like, he's not,
I've upset this person,
that like I'm scared
of his anger a little bit.
- Well, I'm sorry about that.
- Well, that's okay because
now I realize you put your
anger into sketches and
not like actual violence.
So, I don't care what you,
what the kinds of
things your write.
Okay, so. We made out.
I go back to St. Louis
and I didn't realize that he
thought this was now going
to be something more.
- But you were pretty,
like honest about that.
And I remember I was like,
after that happened I was like,
this is a woman I'm
going marry, my life,
I've been a loser my whole life
but things are going
to turn around for me.
- No way.
- Yeah. You know, but,
- [Nikki] I thought,
- [Ian] After what?
After you guys made out?
- Yeah. I felt
that way too when,
if I've hooked up with a
guy that I really liked,
- When you like somebody.
- [Nikki] Yeah,
- And you just see the,
if you're like that's it.
- You project all of
these things onto it
and then that person,
- I've never felt this
feeling since then,
(laughs)
But, I remember I was
with Mike Lawrence at KFC,
and it was right after
the double down
sandwich had come out.
Do you remember those?
- [Nikki] Oh, yeah.
- They're like a
sandwich without bread.
So it's two pieces of
fried chicken, yeah,
so the bun is the
chicken and there's
bacon and cheese and
mayonnaise in the middle of it.
- [Ian} Uh-Huh.
- And I was eating one
of those sandwiches
being like, oh yeah, she's
just so great, you know,
and I'm gonna go see her,
because you were in Hartford,
- [Nikki] Yeah,
- the following weekend, yeah,
I get this text it's like, yeah,
Mike, sorry to be blunt, but I
really just wanna be friends.
And I just had to go back to
eating my double down sandwich.
- Aww, you got rejected.
- With Mike Lawrence.
(laughs)
- It's okay. (laughter)
- Don't worry about it.
- You know, ah,
- I am sorry that,
- Come back to sewer I live
in, we'll put a movie on.
(laughs)
- I'm going to
make 15 jokes about
this movie we watch
after this. (laughs)
- You won't be able to hear
anything at all. (laughs)
Because I have opinions (laughs)
- I remember feeling the
need to write that text
to you because you had
written me the day after
we had made out, 'cause I
flew early that next morning.
I think that's,
- [Mike] Yeah.
Why are we reliving this. Can
I get another seltzer please.
- There's like 40 of them
on the table right here.
- I had probably like a 6
a.m. flight or something,
- [Mike] Yeah,
- 'cause I think I went
right from making out
to being like I have
to pack and leave.
You can have my hotel
room. You can sleep here.
I think that's
how it kinda went.
- Yeah, I think it did.
- [Nikki] Yeah.
So I, but the next morning
I land and I remember
I was on a run the next day,
- I still remember how
the sheets smelled.
and I got a text,
(snorting laugh)
Wow.
- Oh boy, it's all coming back.
- I gotta text,
- And what did it say? What
did it say? This is so funny.
- I can still smell your hair.
- Whoa!
- Yeah. It was
something like that.
That was like, last
night was, it was sweet.
- But here's the thing. If
you were really into it,
that would be a
nice text to get.
- Or!!
- Absolutely
If you couched it, or
if you couched it in a
I had so much fun
with you da da da da.
- I think he couched it.
- And then you responded.
Oh?
- I mean,
- It wasn't just
out of no where?
- I don't think so.
- I can still smell your hair.
- It could have been. But
it was probably was couched,
but that was, I just remember
that being the line that was
like oh no, he really
likes me because that
- But everything
turned out fine.
I'm a men's right
to activist now.
(laughs) (clapping)
- [Nikki] So.
- I've been totally helping
father's rights @god on twitter.
- You're the leader
of the Incel Movement.
I think a woman should have
- I'm having lunch with
Richard Spencer later today.
So everything worked
out for the best.
- Women should legally have
to let you smell their hair.
- But, can I just say,
- Hair is meant to smelled.
- So that was like, that was
kinda like you know whatever,
but you were honest about that.
But then, a month later, this
was, I think May 1st 2010.
No, but it was like a couple
of months later, right.
- Yeah
- You were like,
I'm coming back to New York.
I can't wait to see you.
And I was like,
alright, time to like,
you know, get her back.
- Start working out?
- Yeah, start
working out and like,
I'm gonna be a new
person, you know.
- Yeah, we all all can
relate to this story.
- [Mike] Because, and I wish,
you know I wish looking back
on it I should have
been like, you know,
hey, I really like you and
maybe it's gonna be a while
til we can be friends.
- Yeah. Because I
think just wanted
to go right into friendship,
which I was talking to Ian
about this last night about,
- If there's any young
men listening out there,
don't become a men's right
to activist. (laughter)
Be honest about how
you feel with women.
- [Nikki] Yeah, I think
that's a really good point
to make actually
because when women,
or I've been in
the same position
where I've really like a
guy and I've been like,
I like you and I
wanna be with you,
and he's like, I just wanna be,
I treasure our friendship
too much. And I'd be like,
- He said that? A guy said that?
- Yeah! And I've
been like, okay,
that's fine, yeah
I'm cool with that.
And I am filled
resentment hanging out
with him there on out.
And then he's talking
about girls with me,
and treating me like
a friend, and it just,
you need to take a break.
If you like someone,
don't take the friend card
because you can be
their friend eventually
and you're not a mean person
to reject their friendship,
but just say, I think I
need a little bit of space,
because you not jump
right from liking someone
to being their friend.
And that person is really going
to try to friend-zone you,
and really make it seem like
I want to make good
boundaries here.
So their gonna talk
about guys they're into,
or girls they're into.
And it's going to be
painful, so I would say,
- Yeah, it is going
to be painful.
And you're going to be like,
it's going to be
a weird dynamic,
like you'll showing up with
bagels a nine in the morning
and being like, you
know, you'll be, yeah.
- When did you show
up with bagels.
- No, I'm just saying, like,
you do all these things.
- Have you done that before?
- You degrade yourself.
- Yes.
- Right, and you think that
maybe, you know, in some way,
- Yeah.
- And then secretly your like,
- [Mike] You start
playing games,
- And you're like later if
we hang out, she'll realize,
- [Tom] She's gonna
change her mind.
I had that with this girl who
had to tell me the same thing,
where she was like, I don't
want a romantic thing.
But she was like, sleeping
on my couch all the time.
- [Nikki] Yup.
- And I was like you need to
stop sleeping on my couch.
- You need to stop letting
her sleeping on your couch.
- I know, yeah.
- Wait until she
see's Buck Hunter Pro,
then she'll (laughs)
then she'll want me.
- I mean, I've been on,
recently on the other side
of this where a guy was like,
I just cherish our
friendship so much
and I was smart
enough to know, like,
we're not really
going to be friends.
Like, I care, I
like you too much
and I don't wanna hear
about other girls.
So I stepped away, but then
there are also times where
in recent times where I've
felt like guys getting a crush,
guy friends getting
a crush on me,
and I really try to like,
put a line in the sand
before it's even called out.
- But you admitted
you kind of like
the attention a little bit.
- Yes. Of course. As a woman.
First of all, I
like the friendship.
I like having a guy and
having a guy like you,
they are more, they are in
agreement with you all the time.
They do whatever you
wanna do. (laughs)
You know, when a guy likes
you it's a good energy
as long as he doesn't
actually make a move.
- [Mike] Mmhmmm.
- [Nikki} Do you agree with me?
- I gave you a ride
in my moving van.
- Yeah. I like, and I wasn't
taking advantage of it,
I was honestly trying
to just have a friend,
but it's just, it's a tricky
situation and as a woman
who knows when a guy likes you,
you should really try
to make it very clear
that that is not what it is,
so that they don't get to
the point where they're like,
I like, just to they know
that there's no chance.
- I mean, but then you
look at it, like yeah,
I mean I lost a bunch of
weight, my teeth got whiter,
I started showering, so,
- I once told a guy friend,
- I became a better
man, you know.
- Who I was hanging out with
who I could tell liked me,
I just need you to know it
will never happen, ever.
And if we're going to be
friends you need to accept that.
- And he was like,
ah, a challenge.
- And literally, eight
years later I have the same,
another guy tell me the same
thing, it will never happen,
and that was so freeing
to me to hear never.
- But you don't feel like
it'll never happen between us?
Right? I mean who
knows? (laughter)
- Who knows? We've got a lot
of life to live. (laughter)
- I've never told you never.
- [Tom] Wooo!
- I've never told
Mike Recine that.
- Life is long.
- And that's why we brought
you on the show today.
- [Nikki] So, that's why I
want you here today. (laughs)
- We're gonna re-enact the kiss.
- But I think really,
'cause when you kick
the can down the road
and you go not now,
you know if you're going
to be into someone.
And, you obviously
can't predict how things
are going to change, but,
- I had a thing with
that gal a while ago,
and it was like, so intense and
she kind of lead me on a lot
and we like kissed a bunch,
and then she was like,
I only want to be your friend.
And I was like, but,
but what about ever?
And she goes you need to
think, tell yourself yes.
We will never. And I
was like (gasps), okay.
- You need to, yeah you
need to accept it never.
But that is tricky
situation, because that girl
was making out with you,
some girls will like,
send naked pictures
'cause he's my guy friend,
and I want him and I
want this attention.
And that's really
not nice to do,
and we should all be a
little bit more aware
of other people's feelings,
- Yeah
- And try to empathize with
when someone has a crush on you.
Which I should have done
a better job of instead
of trying to jump
into friendship
with good old Mike
Recine, because,
- Do we really need
to say good, old,
- Here's the thing.
It's very hard to jump
into friendship with me.
- [Ian] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's hard, yeah.
- You're a difficult person.
- Do you have any friends?
- My dog.
(sniffs)
- So, I, moving forward I just,
I think we just didn't, we
weren't friends anymore.
Like, I just think that
your anger about not having
our relationship what
you wanted it to be,
I could just feel
when I was around you,
- [Mike] Yeah, okay,
- I remember one time
we went out to dinner,
and I bought you dinner,
and I was really resentful
because I don't
think you thanked me
soon enough or something.
It was really petty of me,
but I just remember
being like, we're done.
- No, I said I was
take you out to lunch
and then you pulled
your wallet out.
- [Nikki} Uh-Huh.
- Who cares?
- I remember you got, I
remember how much it was.
Is this ridiculous?
- It was like, 33 bucks.
- [Nikki] $17 for
a chicken plate.
At, what's it called?
- Pallitree?
- No, it was a different place.
But I remember being like,
I just, and I was broke.
And I was like I just spent
$17 on a guy who is my friend.
I was so furious,
and so I think,
- And I was like,
I get something out
of this nine month
ordeal. (laughter)
- I don't blame you. So,
- I'm just doing pull-ups
like Travis Bickle,
- So, eventually,
- Are you testing me?
- Ooh, a chicken plate (laughs)
- Mike and I definitely
go our separate ways.
Then let's see, May 29th 2011,
I get an email from Mike.
And I don't have the
original email here.
Hold on. Yes I do. Hold on.
Let me just pull
this up really quick
because I want to
see wrote to me,
'cause Tom sent me what he had,
but it's what you
sent to your brother.
You and your brother co-wrote
this sketch together.
- Here we go.
And I have an email from
my brother being like,
hey, this is really funny,
maybe we could punch it up
a little bit but you
got something here.
- Yup. Yup.
- [Mike] He's like my I dunno,
- Okay. So I can't
find it, whatever.
- [Ian] Enabler?
- Yeah, I'm trying to think
of like, a movie character,
like a shitty, you
know, sidekick.
- Oh, here it is. Hey, Nikki.
My brother and I
wrote this sketch
and there's a part
in it for you.
If you like it let me know.
He rewrote and
reformatted it in his,
I'm not gonna say that word,
blank little film school way,
so I can't figure
out how to change it.
But the only thing I'd take
out is the line at the end,
- I don't use that word
anymore, by the way.
- Okay. But you used a
word, it doesn't matter.
So, you said check out this
sketch, do you wanna be in it,
is essentially what
the sketch was.
Now, I'd love to read the
sketch together, all of us.
- Yeah. Let's pick parts.
- [Nikki] Great.
- 'cause there's four
parts I think, right?
- Oh, great.
- So, I don't
believe there's four.
- No there's three
- Why not, maybe
have Ian play me.
- So. Mike sent me this sketch.
He asked me to be in it.
I'm going to play
Nikki because there's
a part written in it,
- Have Ian play me, so
I can do commentary.
- Okay, I would love that.
- That's a good idea
then I'll be the brother.
- Okay, so Ian is going play
Mike Recine in this sketch.
I'm going to play
myself, which by the way,
Mike made it clear after I
got upset about this sketch,
this was not about me.
- But the character's named,
- [Nikki] Even though the
character's named Nikki,
it's not me.
- Yeah, it could
have been anybody.
(laughs)
- Spelled N-I-K-K-I.
- [Mike] I like to
write people's names,
I like to write people's
name into my projects
so it feels more personal.
- [Nikki] And also,
there's the part of Steve,
which is your real
brother's name, too.
Not the autistic brother.
- Not the autistic.
- I love that this actually
formatted well, too.
It's like a Final Draft.
- He wrote it in Final
Draft. (laughter)
- I asked my mom for
$200 to buy Final Draft
so I could write
this trash (laughs)
- This might be the dumbest
thing written in Final Draft.
- Can you send this to me, I
need to help with formatting.
(laughter)
- This is, so, Mike asked
me to be in the sketch,
and this is the sketch. Okay.
- [Mike] Now, can
I just say again,
I don't remember being mad
at you when I wrote this.
I know you think it's some
kinda revenge thing, and I,
- Well, let's let the audience
decide for themselves.
- Should we start
with the title?
- Wow! Wait! That's so
weird, the first action
is Nikki, a dumb bitch,
walks into a book store.
- Yeah, you're right.
Let's save the title.
- Okay. Fade in. Interior.
- It's good writing.
- Bookstore. Day.
Nikki, late 20's,
browses the book store.
What are we all
laughing at that for?
(laughs)
- [Mike} Because I Think,
- At the time I was
in my late 20's,
- No, you were probably
in your mid-twenties.
- I bet you were earlier
20's then, right?
- Oh, yeah. This
was seven years ago?
- [Mike] 2011.
- [Tom] Or like,
yeah, yes it is.
- 27? Okay, late
20's, that's fine.
Nikki, late 20's
browses the book store.
She sees Steve, early
20's, a familiar face.
Hi, Steve. Weird
seeing you here.
- Why? 'Cause I can't read?
- Nikki's cell phone rings.
- That's a funny
little opening line.
- [Nikki] She checks
who's calling.
Oh my god, Steve,
this is so weird,
your brother is calling me.
- Hey, don't ad lib.
(laughs)
- Don't punch out the script.
- I feel like I have to.
- You can't make
it better. (laughs)
- Oh! Your brother
is calling me?
- She answers the phone.
- I hate this.
- Hey, Mike.
Interior. Mike's apartment.
Mike lazes on the
couch in his boxers
and a Ginnea t-shirt. (laughter)
- Ah, hey Nikki. Just
thought I'd call,
see how you doin'.
- Intercut between book
store and Mike's apartment.
- Oh, I'm good. I'm with
your brother right now.
- Oh, yeah. What
are you guys doin'?
- We banged.
(snorts)
Are banging. It's awesome.
Mike can't believe
what he's hearing.
(laughs)
- Steve, it says
whispering at Nikki.
I don't think
that's a good idea.
- Oh, uh. Mike?
Also, your brother,
he's awesome in the sack.
- Cut to black.
- Let's find some of
Nikki's old emails.
- [Nikki] Okay, so clearly,
- Read them on the air.
- So that's the beginning.
- [Nikki] Clearly the
first scene is me playing
a joke Mike that I'm with
his brother and I'm like,
oh, I'm gonna pretend I'm
having sex with your brother.
- Right. At the book store. Yes.
- Fade in. Exterior. Street
corner. A few days later.
Nikki walks down the
street by herself.
Approaching her is Steve
pushing Mike in a wheelchair.
Mike's movements are jerky and
he makes incoherent noises.
- This is torture.
- His head is
bandaged. (laughter)
Steve pushes the
wheelchair up to Nikki.
- Hi, Nikki.
- Oh my god!
- What? Oh you mean Mike?
- Nikki kneels down
to Mike's eye level.
(sobs) What happened?
- He can't understand
you, Nikki.
He's permanently
retarded. (laughs)
- Nikki springs
to her feet. What?
- Yeah, he tried
to kill himself.
- Oh my!
- It's actually
your fault. (laughs)
You knew he really
liked you, Nikki.
After that joke you
made he got a gun
and tried to kill himself,
but he didn't die.
Sounds messed up,
but I wish he had.
I mean look at him.
- I can't even defend this.
(laughter)
I think this might
be bad writing.
Now that I think
about it. (laughter)
- Mike plays, okay
this is direction.
Mike plays, plays with the pool
saliva forming on his chest.
- Yeah, so now he's
retarded forever,
and I to take care of him.
- What about your parents?
- They're really busy. (laughs)
- This needs to be
wiped from the internet.
- Mike starts to
yell incoherently at
Steve, who leans out,
Ian, do you want to
yell incoherently?
- (yells incoherently)
(laughter)
- What is it, Mike?
Are you hungry?
Do you want to drink
some chicken noodle
soup out of straw?
- (yells incoherently) (laughs)
- Just one more.
- Oh (yells incoherently)
- Mike, try to use your
words. What do you want?
- Eeee. Eeee.
- Oh, you want me to wipe
the drool off your face.
Steve wipes Mike's face.
It's okay, it's okay, Mike.
There you go. You're so brave.
(laughs)
- Nikki buries her face in
her hands and starts to sob.
Close on Nikki's tortured,
guilt-ridden face.
(laughs)
Wider view of Mike standing
up out of the his wheelchair,
taking the bandage off of
his head and looking angry.
- That's what you get for
fucking with my heart, okay!
You really hurt my
feelings (laughs).
- He turns and briskly,
briskly walks away.
Steve (laughs) I can't
even get through this.
- [Tom] This is the best part.
- Steve spits at Nikki's feet.
- The thing is like, you never
see someone's early work.
All we know about
Ernest Hemingway
is that he wrote all
those good books,
but we never saw his
short stories and stuff,
- After Steve
- that never made it.
That got lost in
exchanges, you know.
- Wait! There's one more,
there's one more line,
- You take a journey
as creative person and,
- That's very true.
- You gotta just put
words on the page
if you want to be a writer.
- After Steve spits
at Nikki, he writes,
it says, Steve says,
bitch! (laughs).
Mike, wait up. Steve runs
up to catch up with Nikki,
ah, Mike, while
pushing the wheelchair.
- That's a funny
image. He's like,
chasing after me
with the wheelchair.
(laughs) Oh, I like this the
street sounds for the ambience.
- Great job on the
ambience. Okay.
- Ian? Ian? As someone who
has not heard this before,
or acted in this scene before,
what do you make of this
sketch that he asked me be in?
And I believe I
wrote back and said
I don't want to be
in your sketch, Mike.
I want to find the email
that I wrote to you.
- Nah. That's not important.
- In my response. I
could not believe it.
- The sketch is also
called Retarded Forever.
(laughs) (claps)
- So you thought,
this is how you
worked out your
anger towards me?
- At least I had the balls to
put my feelings on the page.
And send it to the person
who hurt me. (laughter)
- The most passive aggressive,
and asking me to in a sketch!
- That's passive aggressive?
Yeah!
- I don't think that's
passive aggressive.
- [Nikki] No, aggressive
would have been,
Nikki you hurt me, I'm
really angry at you.
That's aggressive.
- No, that would
have been healthy.
- [Mike] You're very right.
- Hah!
- That's something that guys
have to learn, you know.
- [Nikki] Yeah!
- Is like, just that,
- [Nikki] Hold. Hang,
dealing with rejection
in a healthier way.
- [Mike] Dealing with
rejection in a healthier way.
- [Nikki] Yeah.
- 'Cause it's
gonna happen a lot.
- I think it's a good idea
to write sketches and movies
and songs when
you're mad at someone
and you want to work it out.
Like that would have
been a fine sketch
to write and not send me.
- Right. And just keep
it locked in the vault.
- [Ian] And like not use
the character's name, Nikki.
- Also, I had a, my best
friend in high school,
was blamed for a guys suicide,
'cause he wrote a note.
He killed himself
and he wrote a note
and said "I did this 'cause of
you."
So.
- [Mike] Oh, boy.
Very triggering for
me, Mike. Thanks a lot.
- (laughs) Love this,
you just did (laughs)
- But it is true. A lot of
times like, girls get blamed,
- At least that guy got
his point across, huh?
(laughter)
(upbeat rock music up)